We now have seen the full 60 minute interview out
of which Donald Trump abruptly walked last week.
And it's as embarrassing as it is hilarious.
It says dystopian as it is preposterous. And
we're going to look at it. This is the
interview that took place a few days ago
last week. Leslie Stahl was interviewing Donald
Trump at the White House for less. Last night,
60 Minutes episode. And Trump abruptly walked
out early, threaten to release an uncut version
of the interview and did so, proving nothing
other than he's a moron. Now we have a full
proper airing from 60 Minutes, and I want
to get right into it. In this first clip,
Donald Trump just whines. There is no other way
to say it. He whines like he's an underprivileged,
oppressed person rather than the most powerful
person in the world. He whines about how Joe Biden
doesn't get interview questions that Trump wants
him to get. And then this is really wild. Trump
brings up Obama's spied on me and you don't talk
about it. Leslie and Leslie Stahl explains. We
can't air stuff that we can't find evidence
for. And it gets ugly and it gets hilarious.
I wish you would interview Joe Biden like
you interviewed me. It would be so good.
You know what you think that is? I
thought I thought you had my mind on it.
But when I watch him walk out of his store
and he's walking with ice cream and the
question the media asked him, what kind of
ice cream, what flavor? Ice cream do you.
And he's in the midst of a scandal.
He's not. And he's taking
his Lawsie nicely Kaleigh courses. It's the
biggest second biggest scandal. So the biggest
scandal was when they spied on my campaign, they
spied on my campaign. There's no real evidence of
that cause there is no over place. Leslie so spied
on my campaign and they got. Can I say something?
You know, this is 60 Minutes and we can't
put on things. We can't pass it on because
it's bad for Biden. We can't work on things we
can't very. Leslie. They spied on my campaign.
We can't. It's been totally verified now.
It's been just go down and get the papers.
They spied on my campaign. They got caught. No.
And then they went much further than that and they
got caught. And you will see that, Leslie, and
you know that. But you just don't want to know.
As a matter of fact, I don't know that.
Now, what I wish Leslie Stall would have asked
is, Mr. President, sir, as he likes to say, I will
look into this Obama Biden crime if you can tell
me what law you believe was broken, what crime
was actually committed here, because Trump doesn't
know Trump is lost in his own conspiracy theory.
We've seen it before when he's actually asked,
what are you alleging? He says, come on, you know
what it is, unless you're part of the fake news
covering it up. Pathetic Trump. And remember,
Trump thinks this interview makes him look good.
That's one of the most delusional parts of
this. Trump then asked whether insulting
people on Twitter is a good idea. Trump
says it is. But the most notable thing
here is Trump complains more that Leslie Stall's
questions are inappropriate and again complains
about the questions given to Joe Biden.
And then he just gets up and leaves.
Do you think that your tweets and your
name calling are turning people off?
No, I think I wouldn't be here if I didn't have
social media. The tone here is fake. And frankly,
if I didn't have social media, I'd
have no way of getting it in my voice.
Do you know what you told me a long time
ago when I asked why you keep saying fake
media? Yeah. You said to me, I say that
because I need to disc discredit you
so that when you say negative things about me, no
one will believe I don't have to discredit you.
But that's what you discredited yourself. You
know, I didn't want to have this kind of anguish.
You did? No, I didn't push it. No, I did.
Well, then you brought up a lot of subjects.
Well, I said approximately tough
questions. They were inappropriate.
Right from the beginning. Now, your first question
was, this is going to be tough questions. Why you
don't ask Joe Biden. I saw your interview with
Joe the interview. I never did a Joe wasn't Joe.
The interview, 60 Minutes. I see Joe
Biden giving softball after softball.
I've seen all of his interviews. He's
never been asked a question. That's hard.
Okay. But forget him for. You know, when
you start president. Your president.
Excuse me, Leslie, you started
with me. Your first statement was.
Are you ready for tough questions,
are you? That's no way to no Ed..
Leslie, one on one side at this point.
One of our producers interrupted to
advise about the time remaining in the interview.
I think we have enough of an interview here. OK,
that's enough. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go
meet for two seconds. OK. Thanks. I'll see
a little. Thanks.
Be careful.
Can you imagine a more whiny president
whine, whine, whine. And then I think
we have enough. He says, I think we have
enough. Bye-Bye. Here is the moment where
Trump actually does the walking out in Press
Secretary Kelly McCann, and he comes in with
that oversize book. And it's it's just total
cringe. I would be ashamed to be Kaley McEnany.
She deserves never to work again after this
nightmare is over. There's actually a long
list of people associated with this clown
that deserve to never work again. But I mean,
this is just if you're allergic to cringe,
I would probably turn away at this point.
We were scheduled to take a walk with the
president around the White House grounds.
I've got a lot of questions I didn't ask
while we waited to see if the president was
coming back. His press secretary, Kaley
McEnany, came in with a hand delivery.
Presently, the president want me to deliver
his health care plan a little heavy.
Oh, my God. This is his health care plan. Yes. OK.
Kelly, thank you. You're welcome. Now, the vice
president is certainly. OK. And the president's
not coming back. The president getting a laugh.
It was heavy, filled with executive
orders, congressional initiatives,
but no comprehensive health plan.
So not all the pages were blank. There
was actually some stuff in there. Meaningless
stuff. And as Leslie Stahl points out.
Nothing in there about Trump's supposedly
forthcoming health care plan. Trump again raises
this idea that covered cases are rising merely
because of more testing. He's sticking with that.
Four years ago, you were behind
in the polls, as you are now.
And you pulled it out. But this time
you have kind of a double Migrante.
You have unemployment claims going
up. You have covered cases going up.
I mean, it's like the gods have suddenly decided
decided to conspire against each other. So, no,
I think. Well, what about Jeb with kov it, sir?
Excuse me. Cases are up and about 40 states.
No cases are up. Also, because we do more testing,
the fake news media loves to say cases are up.
The fact is, we've done a very,
very good job as we have done.
That's right. Because we're doing so much testing.
There is increased testing. But according to the
Colvert tracking project, that doesn't account for
all of the rise in new cases sweeping the country
or the 40 percent increase in
hospitalizations in the past month.
Understand that this is an easily debunked big
lie. Testing is up four percent over the last
week. Cases are up 21 percent. If you want to
make the case that cases are only up because
testing is up. If you test 10 percent more and
find 10 percent more cases, you might be able to
make that argument. You might be able to make the
argument that this is roughly the number of cases
that was there all along were just testing more
people and making more of those cases official.
But when you test four percent more in cases go
up 21 percent and hospitalizations are up, you
understand that it's a lie. This is an existential
threat. This man is an existential threat that
must be removed and he's lying to you every
day. Whether he understands that the math of it.
Probably not. But he is lying every day. And then
lastly on Trump, before we move to one pence clip,
Leslie Stall. Good for her. Calls out
Trump on the health care plan that he's
been promising for months. And Trump says
we're going to announce it very, very soon.
You promised that there was
going to be a new health package,
health care plan. You said
that it was going to be great.
You said it's ready. It's going to be ready and
it'll be here in two weeks. It's going to be like
nothing you've ever seen before. And of course,
we haven't seen it. So why didn't you develop?
A health plan is developed. It is fully
developed. It's going to be announced very soon
when we see what happens with Obamacare.
If the Supreme Court ends this Obamacare,
well, we're gonna have to see what happens.
I think I I hope that the end
it'll be so good of them if they end
up people with preexisting conditions
will be stranded. And that's just a fact.
It's in a. A new plan will happen. Well,
we won't do anything. Will and is. We
won't do anything. And no plan unless
we have preexisting conditions coverage.
Of course, at this point, I don't know that
anybody believes that. This plan actually exists.
Remember that in August, Donald Trump said to
Chris there's video of Trump promising it in 2017
and 2018 and 2019. But more recently, in August,
Trump said during that bizarre interview with
Chris Wallace, we are going to sign a new health
care bill into law in two weeks. And, of course,
it's almost November at this point. It probably
doesn't exist. Here is Leslie Stall after Trump
walked out asking Vice President Mike Pence why
did Donald Trump end his interview early? Pence
just has no idea how to respond. Take a look.
While our interview with the
president did not go forward to the
one scheduled with the vice president, did.
So what just happened with the president?
Leslie? President Trump is a man who speaks his
mind. I think it's one of the great strengths
that he's had. But he was president of the
United States. And the American people always
know where they stand. Biden is always ready and
the American people know that in this time, it's
it's it's less about the back and
forth with the media. And it's
it's really more about how we bring
this country all the way back.
What? Why did Trump leave? Mr. Vice President,
the president is always ready, Leslie. The
president is always ready. An embarrassment. But
remember, Trump as a narcissist probably can't
even acknowledge or comprehend that this was an
embarrassment. And in fact, Trump thought the raw,
uncut video make made him look good. And
he released it a few days ago. I do think,
despite Donald Trump's weaponized narcissism
and inability to feel shame. I do think if he
loses to Biden the way he might lose if we all get
out and vote and the votes are counted properly.
I actually do think Trump may be ashamed by by
losing to Joe Biden badly because he's alluded to
it. He said, can you imagine if I lost to this
guy? Can you imagine if I lost to this worst
candidate or whatever it is that he says? I
think that that will actually bring shame to
Donald Trump. Just a bonus primary reason
to vote Biden is to start writing the ship
of the United States very far down the list.
But interesting nonetheless, is Donald Trump
actually being ashamed of being brutally
defeated by Joe Biden? Let's make it happen